all right hello everyone welcome to
another awesome language design review
part of our incremental language
development series
and we have a variety of topics today
first one strings strings string strings
better cuts
yeah so we're gonna be talking about a
handful of predicates here so I just
took the liberty of listing all of our
existing string predicates just for
reference
um under the first sub item
or fairly standard complement string
format Q is kind of an outlier there
what is it
uh it is
it does the string meet this format
it is does this string meet this import
export format yeah
it's not
it's not a normal string pattern it's
specifically tied into the import export
format
okay
so string pattern queue is actually a
function that has been implemented about
six different times in different private
contexts in the system
um
and it it's primarily useful because
there's a bunch of different things that
can be string formats we can't just test
ahead and say is it a string or is it a
pattern it might also be a regular
expression or or some combination
thereof yeah but but you can't always
just put a regular expression in places
where you put a string pattern
and like if I have a string partner the
form you know
X colon digit character Ray dot dot till
the tilde blah blah blah blah blah
that's different from
you know the regex form
right I mean all all of the string
patterns ultimately do have a regular
expression representation but sure they
do as regular expression of blah blah
blah right
well I mean if we're going to have this
it needs a second argument which
determines what type of string pattern
it's asking for
by making sense yeah I think that's a
good qualification so what whether it's
I mean by default it might allow a star
or it might allow you know because the
analog of that would be
you know
um
quotes a I know the Stars anything yeah
star is anything so it's this right yep
those are alternate representations of
the same right but that doesn't work
there are functions for which that
doesn't work extremely place you know
doesn't won't take that right yeah
because it's specifically looking for a
pattern-based version rather than wild
card
so yeah that's a good point that there
need to be some qualifications for
string patterns in some cases do we have
an option that means allow these kinds
of wild cards we do don't wait for some
functions
use a very old option I believe you're
right I don't know the option name off
the top of my head though
um
uh
well let's find out I mean I think
there's a what would anybody know what
that is
it's in um
maybe information or something has that
I'm not sure
can we look that up because we could
have it be an option
or we can have it be a second argument
here I think it needs something yeah
I'll I'll follow up on that
um kind of a specific implementation
so the next two are closely related
string disjoint q and string
intersecting Q
I didn't know that that was character
intersection I mean yeah this is
specifically
characters I think there there's a
little bit of a Nuance difference
between
the the
character forms versus the string forms
I think so I thought this meant
do these strings overlap
you see what I'm saying
yeah so I mean there's yeah there's the
version of do these contiguous elements
overlap versus do the component
characters in them overlap
you know I think the I think we actually
have Arnold here but these were
originally versions that are new
proposed and they're trying to map to
what intersecting queue and disjoint Q
do which is looking at individual
elements but I know but I don't think
this is what I mean
go ahead well I was just gonna say I
mean what is the use case for these and
and why is it you know sort of so
compelling that that you can't just run
you know intersecting queue of
characters yeah
I'm not buying these
but I do think something I was trying to
do recently with
um sequence alignment
is something where you have two strings
and you're trying to figure out whether
you can line them up you know at the
beginning or the end
that's what I'm saying
yeah whether the specific sequence of
characters have an intersection I mean
if I do this
and then I have another string
that's you know x c c c
i want to I want to align those
strengths that's something that I wanted
to do a bunch of times and it's not too
hard to write the code but there's a
function a function repository with your
name on it related to that
how funny
well actually maybe a more General
version of this that that that like uh
I've wanted for some llm things is uh
you give it a string and a pattern and
the question is could this string be the
prefix of a string that matches that
pattern
so for example you might have a pattern
like oh I want any number of I just want
a bunch of letters followed by a DOT
right so then if I have a bunch of
letters that doesn't match that string
pattern but it could be the beginning of
a string that matches that pattern
is that not a wrapper for the for the
pattern
for the string pattern that can ask that
not that I know of
um
I don't think so but I could be wrong
okay but let's see what is this doing
this is asking
okay this is asking for cases where the
strings
can overlap
this would be a more low level
string of a lapse Q
right I mean this is in any order
but this is just asking
can this string you know
what is the unified version of the
string with the overlap implemented
and
you know how much overlap is there
right
this is this is useful I mean this is
useful for bioinformatics stuff it's
useful for these kinds of things that
you know for strongly writing stuff
that I use this for
let me understand what Christopher is
asking right I think this came out early
in the physics project
makes sense that was about that time
okay so what was Christopher asking for
in more detail you want to know
whether a particular pattern
you know this like string prefix Q or
something
with one possibility
right is this well is this uh string a
prefix of this pattern kind of ish
okay so the use case to be clear that
you know that I ran into was you know
you're generating tokens from an llm and
you want to know do the tokens so far
could these you know match some pattern
so for example if I only want to
generate text that you know matches a
certain string pattern you know there's
no point in continuing if already it's
generated a token that couldn't possibly
match the pattern
yes
but but maybe the right way to do it I
mean one way to do it would be to have a
different string match Q string prefix Q
function another way would be if we had
some some uh you know pattern construct
for it I mean this is maybe you know
much more complicated to do but you know
uh
right like you have a wrapper for the
string pattern that says you know match
any string you know that's a prefix of
of this pattern
okay but we already have things like
start of string which is a pattern thing
imagine it's true which is a prefix of
this pattern
okay so we met match
a string that is a prefix
of blah blah blah so what would that be
for a list
what is the pattern
that is a prefix of
so that means
that's a prefix of I'm confused by that
another way you could think about it is
there is a possible completion to this
string that makes it match the pattern
it's a potential match for the pattern
but not a complete match right right but
there there exists uh another string
that you can attend to the end of this
one that makes it match the pattern
right
but this is okay so
go ahead
I was gonna say if so example you're
looking for XYZ in a pattern and you
have X Y it is potentially a match
but it's unfinished right is that the
idea of a string right but if you had x
x then it couldn't possibly match right
yeah so yeah right so let's understand
match a string that is a prefix of
is a prefix of
so
you're asking for something which is the
the um
uh
let's see
it's like a string prefix pattern or
something but that's not really right in
other words that matches any string
employment that is a prefix of means
what means that the string
that you are matching with this
I'm very careful I'm not sure the word
prefix is quite right yeah it's like an
incomplete pattern or potentially
incomplete
yeah if that's the pattern you're
looking for
what's that
it's a string that has this as a prefix
is that is that it
I think the idea is this is the pattern
I'm looking for x y z I want an input
that is X Y to return true but an input
that is X x to return false it is a
partial pattern match or a potential
an incomplete pattern match maybe the
string XX
to do that is this not trivial to do
with string starts Q in like a pattern
test
the thing only matches the beginning so
in other words as far as it goes it
matches this
right string starts to use kind of the
the inverse thing it's saying that that
uh what is it it's basically saying that
this pattern matches the beginning of
the string as opposed to the string
matches the beginning of the pattern
Ian is commenting here
that this would be the case
that string starts Q
I'm very confused here well I mean
string match Q of string comma string
prefix pattern of string would also
return true
yes that's right not the starts part
right I see
I mean even the start would work as well
but yeah yes but let me just understand
what this is so this means
why am I being so confused here that
this is
this means
maybe to try try an example that's more
pattern-y so if you write something like
you know letter character dot dot
squiggle
you know
quotes period or something right so it's
basically any series of letters followed
by a period or semicolon no
so if you wrote string prefix pattern of
that
then then this pattern would match a a b
a b q a b q semicolon but it would not
match a one or something like that
so it would match anything that you
could complete to form a string that
matches the pattern
so but this is the wrong name for that
construct so does this yeah does this
take only string literals or both string
literals and string patterns but it
takes the string pattern here
like this represents look I was thinking
it was a pattern that matches the
prefixes of a specific string no it's
this for example matches anything this
is the thing which
what is the right name for this this is
something where you want it to match
this
um
my God what should this be it's maybe a
little bit like
I mean it's a little bit like up to I
mean maybe it could be something like
well
prefix of pattern or something it's a
little obscure
um
but the point being that it matches
anything that's a prefix of this
right
I guess I keep circling back to the idea
that it's a potentially incomplete
pattern you know let's say another
example of an application would be I
have some definite genetic sequence that
I'm looking for that I have a whole
bunch of data that has incomplete
genetic sequences
if they're all starting points you know
I can filter out and say Here's you know
a 30 chromosome pair or 30 chromosome
sequence that I'm looking for I want to
discard everything that just doesn't
even begin the right way
yes but the only thing is about that the
word complete is I think complete kind
of I don't know like it it sort of
implies that like it should be complete
or something that like this is a yeah
it's sort of like some weird value
judgment on the string or something I
don't know
look I want to come back to the case
that I've found important which is this
question of whether
two strings can
you know this is what you need to
reassemble a shotgun sequencing thing
in in bioinformatics for example right
do these things
you know can you puzzle piece match
these things together
you see what I'm saying right that's a
related one
um
maybe you could Implement that I'm
thinking of whether this would actually
quite give you that
um you might need to do some either have
a string ends Q or maybe you can just
emulate that with string reverse or
something
well I think the useful thing would be
given these sequence of strings
isn't there already a function that does
that longest common sequence where
you're talking about something else
the strings are potentially disjoint
yeah but the longest common sequence
doesn't do that because it's not an end
to end thing right
you're supposed so long as common
subsequence I know but that's not
no alarm in I mean if you just want to
do this joining right and you have the
explicit strings that I think you can
probably use the longest common sequence
but but as long as common sequence only
work at the two ends or doesn't it work
it works anywhere yeah you see that's
not right we need a thing that works
only at the end
right but it's not too hard to then you
can call longest common sequence and
then check whether that sequence
that's incredible waste
right but but in any case I I think that
the I mean the reason why why the
pattern thing is more interesting is
just that it it's this is something it's
a pure
like
you don't need string patterns to do
this shotgun sequencing problem right
like these it doesn't matter if they're
lists or or strings or whatever I know
that problem right but I mean this
we need something that does this case
the strings are all lists
so that's one function we're going to
need
but so yeah go ahead finish your thought
and I'll come back to it okay but then
then separately this thing about
I still haven't wrapped my brain around
this particular thing go go ahead what
were you gonna say yeah so I I was gonna
say there's potentially two cases we're
looking for with the longest overlaps
you know are we looking for
concatenate these strings together with
overlaps if they're there or are we
looking for you know any cases where
these potentially overlap is is this
sort of a cases instance or are we
looking specifically for joined strings
to come out of it and
successful cases I think we want both I
think we want look the case is the thing
we want is
uh you know join the strings
buy their overlaps you know
um
we want
probably just give me the longest
overlap and I can do string length that
I want to know how long it is
or length
okay
and I would argue that what we want here
is longest overlap
that goes you know string one string two
it's very clear what that means if we
had string one strength choose string
three
you know there's clearly a longest
overlap between string one and string
two string two and string three
how do we return that
so I guess the question is what you do
when they're entirely disjoint is
the longest overlap in that case is just
no it's just no Nostrand
but I mean it's unfortunate
right you want a string in the first
case and in the other case you basically
need to have a list
which is unfortunate
but why don't you want to return a
single string again joining a string
three to the joining of one and string
two
I think in this case we're looking
specifically for what the overlap
sequence is rather than the joined
string oh I see I see okay yeah I think
in the in the various case of the join
these strings together you would just
have
the strings get joined together with
whatever overlaps laying on top of each
other
and if they're disjoint I guess they'd
just be joined end to end
I mean string drawing overlapped or
something but that isn't the right name
and also these could be both lists and
strings
right although I have to say I think the
string case is more useful for the
overlapping thing
maybe there's some use case with byte
sequences on files or something where
you have fragments that's true too I
mean this this business about
reassembling things that have been
fragmented is definitely a thing that
comes up
and I can even imagine that you might
want in some cases to do it even when
there is some uh you know edit distance
that you're not getting right
I really think this is a good thing yeah
I really think this is a good thing now
I still haven't understood this thing
should we should we try and explore this
thing further or is it is the
how worthwhile is this thing I think
maybe I'll I'll talk to Christopher
outside of this a little bit and we'll
try and get the the use case down a
little bit but this really does seem
useful okay again I've run into it
multiple times it it must have a name
and bioinformatics because it you know
it is the thing you need to reassemble a
shotgun sequence
you know DNA sequence or something
make sense yep yeah I'll check in with a
couple of people and we'll Circle back
okay
so this last one is similar to the sorry
it's similar to the what is image
assemble that does this that helps with
naming yes that's kind of an analog
and in fact assembly is exactly what
it's called in bioinformatics
that's not a bad name String Assemble
I like that name it's also well I mean
there's also uh the analogous most
similar function I can think of is image
line
but it still might be confusing with
sequence align which does something kind
of different
right but what is an image Assemble
no image a line no I know but images
symbol just image assembles like string
drawing
no I think I think you're talking I know
it doesn't Advanced usage Advantage
assemble that does it but
you can especially intelligently I don't
think oh is it not intelligent okay
I think it just yeah it's like string
drawing
okay
so that's an argument against this okay
I mean it would be lovely to have a name
that would allow us to work for Strings
analysts
we'll let that one simmer a little bit
and we'll Circle back to it next time
with a more concrete proposal
okay
all right string within Q
yeah so the name here isn't great the
actual function that's being proposed is
looking for sub expressions
that match a string or string pattern
here
yeah so yeah that's specifically so the
second argument is a string pattern and
it's looking at all sub-expressions
within the first argument to see if
anything
contains I mean that's amusing but it's
it's a crazy name
right yeah I think you know contain
string Q is closer but it's
not quite how far down does it why why
does this I mean I I just don't
understand what the I mean is this not
just like member queue
with no logos like Infinity
no because not member queue because it's
look basically what this is doing is
it's doing a search a string search
right if this had been written out as
input form this would be like a string
search
right
I don't even know what the heck it's
supposed to return
that it's there that's not all that
useful yeah I mean the the cases I run
into this are you're doing something
like you're scraping through XML or
you're scraping through some sort of web
dump and I've got a whole bunch of data
and I need to pick out which
you know which of these elements
actually has the sequence I'm looking
for I've got a bunch of Auto data that's
dumped out and I'm trying to find the
VIN numbers I know what the VIN number
patterns look like they're a sequence of
13. so you can use string cases yeah
yeah you can use string cases when it's
a single large string but if I've got a
bunch of XML data that's being stored as
XML elements it's trickier right so the
problem with that is
that string cases doesn't work on a
thing that isn't I mean I don't know
whether if I say string cases of this
you know
a list of strings here
and I say
you know something like a
dot dot
right
what's wrong with that
I see I see it's giving the same
structure for a list it's giving the
same structure the issue is that string
cases doesn't have a form that
rodentifies to use our old terminology
like a burrowing rodent mm-hmm
and so this is
this is like adding a level spec to a
string contain skill
yes right but but it's also the same as
just member queue of the expression
comma string contains Q of the pattern
comma Infinity
well look like you can just use member Q
to make any function
effectively uh
identifying freak you
how do you do that in this case okay so
how does it work in this case
right can you write member queue or
maybe not free queue but but let's try
member Q
uh of the expression
yeah
and then comma underscore question mark
parentheses
string contains Q
of your pattern
and then comma Infinity outside the
string contains Q like out the number Q
you might have to do zero to Infinity
but yeah
okay great how do I actually find the
strings
position
instead of member queue
and you know we have a whole bunch of I
mean and if you want to know how many
strings there are you could use count
right like it's sort of uh we already
have a bunch of functions for doing this
kind of drilling down if the only thing
this adds is that it drills down and it
also drills down into Strings it's not
hard to put those together already
why doesn't that work
the like doesn't have a level spec let
me
yeah the third argument of Select is
which um
uh
is how many results to return yeah
there's no level
it's not clear what that would be I
think
yes right because it's not clear that it
returns these cases
yeah
but then I've got to have this construct
here
yeah which is what you have in all the
other you know and count as well and
member queue as well a position so it's
it's very I wonder whether we should
have a a piece of sort of a name for
this thing blank question mark blah
pattern test is the name right
yeah yeah
so if I just say here is there
one argument for one argument pattern
test
I don't actually know I don't know
there should be
I mean the real thing is just yeah the
parentheses on the underscore question
mark thing are always weird too right so
yeah this would be nice because it would
avoid debt
binding issue
we should introduce that a one argument
fall path and test
and it would just be a
yeah okay blank question mark blah right
just a test
yeah that'll be real nice I'll use that
[Music]
the one thing that string within to you
if it was a position thing could do is
it could tell you when it finds a string
where in the string is the pattern right
like string position does
that's like the last time sorry what so
what were you saying the one thing that
we could add with a dedicated function
in this conversation
is you could say where within the string
the pattern is like string position does
and how would you return that
as the last element in the in the result
of each position spec
honestly I would argue that instead of
returning as the last element you would
have to return it as a pair like here's
the position and then here's the string
position
look the mixed
expression position and string position
we've never done and it seems fairly
horrible it does it does
okay the format yeah we could come up
with a better formatting of the output I
don't know I'm just trying to come up
with a reason to have
this
yeah I mean I heard I had not
necessarily thought of the form that
Christopher mentioned and I think like
we said maybe
touching up pattern test makes using
patterns like that a lot easier we
should have thought of that sometime in
the last 35 years one argument from that
test it's a good idea I think we
discussed it in May of this year
really the mail archive Link in the chat
we should do it and also an optional
third argument for a level spec for
select but I'd have to review if we okay
I think that one seems much more
questionable
all right let's continue here
since we're talking about string
contains uh it's a proposal on the wfr
to have a string contains all
no okay why do we want this I mean it
just seems like a very sort of puzzle
solving
obscure thing
for lists contains all
I don't even know whether that's you
know sorts or equivalent or unions or
equivalent or what
is this sort is equivalent or sorts are
equal or unions are equal
believe its unions are equal
yeah like contains all and all the
contained ones I think they're all just
just synonyms for set operations
like subset q and so on
yes that's correct
I don't get this I don't get the points
of this
yeah I mean I guess again this you know
this is a fairly typical use case the
string contains all
right I don't understand what is the
operator form of it yeah I realize that
I mean so I think it's testing that the
string contains both naturalist and
inhabitants correct I think that's
what's happening yes it is providing a
list of substrings that need to be
inside the
the string you're looking at a while
string contains doing this
is
because string contains you give it a
single pattern yes it's looking for a
single pattern string contains all would
potentially take multiple patterns so
this isn't similar to all look look look
it's this case right that's no it's me
but not all right yeah
but but you could you could do this with
just I mean if you run string contains
to you end times maybe that's
inefficient I mean I'm looking this is
from Jason Biggs so I'm guessing this is
a there's some if you have a you know a
genome sequence or something and you
want to know does this uh I don't know
that just does genome sequences I think
that one well but okay but the thing you
could imagine I think you can imagine is
I've got this genetic sequence and I've
got these these three sequences that
correspond to some genes or something
like that and I want to know do all
three of these genes appear but it seems
like I should just run string contains
to you three times
right
well you can also run
uh you know it'll be all true
look the if this was going to exist it
would be string contains all Q
right that will be the correct
would it not be that because it's the
it's the analog of string contains Q
but it's where we're forcing all of
these the alternative will be a wrapper
around this
this thing here
right like and
or all true
what's the outline of the patterns of
all true
we have a contains all
right yeah this is specifically an
analog of the contains all function what
what we've got string contains q but yet
we have contains all
as a non-q function
is that correct right the contains
family of functions are not Q functions
because they have operator forms I
believe
but so does string contains doesn't it
it has an operative form as well okay I
I don't remember the Genesis of the
contains family well enough to say
exactly why they're not
Q predicates
well I mean look string contains all Q
is okay except that it's annoying that
it doesn't merge correctly with contains
all
that's what I'm saying
right I mean we don't have headdresses
anywhere else that I'm aware of where we
have a implicit or
for you know we were talking about
having a decorator for the second
argument of string contains q that would
say yeah this is an and and I can't
think of any other instance where we
have an implicit or and some sort of
headdress that changes it to an and
right it's the opposite in text search
right what is the address and text
search well list means and
and Alternatives means or
which is what we should have done with
string contains Q
they would because we don't have what's
that they would at least be aligned in
that case yeah
although I do that you think the old
case is more common here
[Music]
um
right generally when you're giving a
list of patterns
they're probably Alternatives though you
can give a single pattern with
alternatives
would be the Counterpoint isn't there a
general pattern construct that means
all of these must be in here
like for example we don't have a pattern
combination that this thing matches both
you know because we could have something
that says it matches both blah blah
or let's say Let me let me give a more
extreme case
right
we don't have that construct
its Alternatives is just the or but we
don't have the and case you can't we
don't have the app we can't say and of
two patterns
I think that's come up I think Nick had
a case of where he brought that up
[Music]
you know that seems like
yeah can I ask um this is the end of two
patterns
saying that the expression matches both
of those patterns exactly
so that seems different from the
contains case where you're giving two
patterns and you want two different
Expressions to match
you know
yeah
yes
Sandra on our live stream goes a piece
of code here for
the case that we're talking about
right right that's correct what's your
work just fine but yeah could be more
efficient with a dedicated
function
let's explore this question about a
rapper that means
I'm not sure
I do think this is worth looking at
match this pattern and this button
but
it should be called Alternatives of two
l's
I'm I'm weakly positive about string
contains all cue
okay well we'll we'll put that as a
subject to revisit when talking about a
inclusive and all-inclusive pattern
this looks bonkers
is it just switch but instead of giving
a pattern in the first argument you give
a string pattern expression or first
argument yeah so you're or
right I mean it's just right in every
every odd numbered argument you give a
string pattern instead of an expression
pattern correct yeah I think I mean I
think the point is that switch is a kind
of a skill function anyway
I mean a better form of this which I
just don't understand why this isn't you
know this should be
string replace
of
this thing here
comma list
you know
what those as rules what successes are a
one which looks much nicer to me
is this not equivalent
what's that
the
to the rule
right yeah yeah
you need parentheses yeah
wait you shouldn't you can actually
check that
no the questions is right no you're
right
but that is a strange error it's a
string strange expression of two is just
if you do squiggle squiggle
like swiggle swiggle is the index
restring expression right
yeah but this
that's really weird oh oh oh well
I'm not sure where the string expression
maybe it's because it's
it's replacing yeah no no no no because
string the right hand side yeah the
right hand side needs to be a string and
string replaced
yeah right so this is the problem the
problem is it's not replacing the whole
string this is like replace more like
replace all kind of than it's like
replace
yeah so how do I do how do I do a whole
string replacement here
and then for the pattern you use you
know underscore question mark string
match queue
or in the future pattern test of string
match Q
that's pretty bluffy
spring switch seems a lot nicer than
that approach
I don't think so I think switch is a
horrible horrible mess
with you know uneven numbered things I
mean something where you say
it's a very procedural construct right
yeah I just don't think it's a very good
construct I think this is a much better
construct but the question is for
replace
I mean if this was
if this was replaced
and this first argument was
you know characters of this
right
and this
is this
is first it's string split would do it
instead of string replace
what happens
yeah yeah that works fine
[Music]
you could also change string replace to
string split and put a first
in front and it should work
why does that work
string split with rules as a second
argument
replaces
interesting
um the left hand side with the right
hand side and it can be any expression
because it doesn't try to join them
again yeah I didn't realize that it
didn't need to be a string
well I think this functionality that
it's a string pattern going to an
arbitrary thing for the whole string is
useful
the fact that it has to be back to a
string is really kind of yucky
um
I think we figured out why somebody
decided to make a resource function
I still honestly think that this is just
a very obscure thing to want to do yeah
I mean you have to write a little bit
more more characters you have to write a
pattern test
but
it's not that bad
well the only thing I can imagine
I'm
I I can see this showing up in a whole
bunch of scraping like code
yeah I was thinking there's scraping
like code or some sort of prompt
handling code you know if I get
some input that has a question mark I
call a different function or
a very what do we even do with this I I
don't think this is I mean
[Music]
um
if we can think of a really great name
for this thing that represents this kind
of whole string replacement
perhaps there's a future for this
okay
for the use cases we just talked about
you want string contains instead of
string match yeah what I mean yeah
so I
right I don't know I I it just seems
like it's a really obscure
all right
thing
I'm just not buying any of these string
set functions I'm just not buying these
I just don't understand why you can't
just say characters
yeah I mean in this you know the these
were a handful of functions we pulled I
think these were all our nude functions
but originally you know the idea is
basically you're pulling out just as you
see their characters and then doing set
operations and maybe that's
not really that interesting
I don't see it I mean why can't you do
it with
complement in this case complement of
characters I mean is this wrong if I if
I say compliment
of
characters of this
yeah it's in a different order what does
it mean that it's a different order
it's sorting them complements sorting
them
I know that I mean string complement is
not for some reason
what's the argument for string
complement not to sort them
yeah I probably should certainly a
string Union an intersection resorting
them so well then this then it's just a
string drawing of this
[Music]
I'm not buying it
perhaps there is a possibility that the
contains family could do this itself it
currently doesn't do anything on two
strings
what do you mean
so the contains family currently works
on on two lists or two associations
um lists and associations
I think we have some functions of the
work both on lists and on strings oh
absolutely yeah like those longest
subsequence all the dissimulated
dissimilarity measures work on lists and
strings so I'm just saying that the
contains family could decide to apply
characters to Strings okay but what what
is the content what would the contains
family do so you're saying compliments
could do that for example
things
yes but I I think complement feels more
set related contains my
what what like what contains function
the five contains X contains all
contains none contains exactly
well I agree I don't see any downside to
doing that
seems very sensible to me
I put in the chat uh function Rick made
in the function repository called string
function to basically
yeah applies any set based function to
the characters right it just does
characters in the end of the string
joint right it's just a wrapper
um
which you know
it is nice because we had a whole bunch
of these come to function repository and
this sort of stem that died of having a
dedicated function for each one
maybe this is the right answer
this is nice
yeah like permutations is nice there
rather than having string permutations
this is nice I would use this a bunch of
places
that's better because then then we could
just say presumably we can say string
function
of contains all
and then the arguments
blah blah blah blah
yeah we're interested that what if you
had an option for contains all or for
these functions that was like
uh make it as for Strings or something
no
yeah I don't think we want an option
that changes what heads it operates on
no absolutely not
should the name be something more like
characters applied
yes it should be
or string applied
right and in the case where there's more
than one argument you know each each
function will have to have a little bit
different logic potentially as opposed
to what's pulled apart and what's not
right
okay yeah I'll tear into what the thorny
cases on that are strong applied is
interesting it's really quite
interesting
that's really quite nice
okay so that would in fact give us all
of these strings sort
what a strong prepared
basically just a special case of string
drawing same with string append
why do we care
I understand what's the difference
between this and
string join except that has an operator
Fork
that primarily there's an operator form
I mean the I guess the same notion of
why we have prepend and append and join
but
no
depend on a pen take different list
structures right because list
a single element they take single
elements rather than lists right
I much prefer string applied I think
that's a much better thing
okay so this is circling back to
something we we've talked about one or
two times in the past which is the idea
of
splitting a list before after or at a
specific case the last time we went
around it we linked the idea of a split
cases as a generalized ver version of it
or the split cases
the idea basically being that we give a
pattern where we split it and we can
pull out elements before after or at the
specific
splitter rather than having a dedicated
before after an act
okay so what do you mean what how does
it that work
I mean basically we're looking
yeah
uh
you know with a split before we
basically are looking at a specific
pattern and then we are
segmenting the list or in this case
before so in other words you're saying
is that
if split for example
I mean this
ordinary string split
I don't know why I always type splot
instead of split I do it every damn time
I don't know why you know what function
word
okay so the issue is what happens to the
separator in here
okay so why isn't split
oh I see split has a test
rather than split at
which will be another function but we
could have is split at
right
[Music]
all right so you're saying that string
split could have an assembly argument
yeah basically what do we do with the
the separator or the
look you see we got all these things
[Music]
right because rule is a replacement
and you I could just use the options
that
um string template has insertion
function and combination function
I suppose
[Music]
I'm not sure if that accomplishes what
word main objective here
what would be the main what would be the
points of insertion function
I mean yeah it's a little different than
is in string template right
yeah it is I mean really what this is is
a post splitting function
what you've got
is
what do you want to do you've got
two elements you've got the the
separator
right so you've got the the separator
I suppose you've got the before string
and you've got the after
right
and for every split
you've got those three things which
might which obviously the separator is a
pattern and not explicit you also have
the things that matched
well I'm saying the separator is the raw
separator not not the input it's the
it's what actually matched so it's a
list in general
well as long as it's the separator the
separator each for each element here
like this might be
BBB
dash dash dash dash
that's the separator this is a separator
specific list so this will be a list oh
I see okay I see okay so you have a list
of these associations
that happened before and after might
also I was thinking it was the
transverse of what you have here
I'll be saying about before and after I
was saying before and after it could be
start of string or end of string
potentially for the first and last
elements
they could be yes
and by the way I have no idea if you
know something like string join
I bet this doesn't work
yeah doesn't work I mean that could work
I think it generally doesn't work on
patterns right no I agree but yeah but
it could work for this case
all right so in the split case the
question is
I mean or is it the case that all that
really happens is
what's the residue that gets left after
splitting how much of the separator is
left after the splitting right you know
in in data scraping your delimiters are
sometimes meaningless markup they might
be colons sometimes they're meaningful
you might have records that are
separated by dates and so you might have
a date pattern and say I want to stick
that with the element before it
rather than just throwing it in the band
yeah
okay so let's think about this for a
second so what other functions do we
have
and I agree templates are an example
maybe not much of an example
no they're not really much of an example
what other functions do we have which
pick up a thing
that is essentially metadata
or something like metadata
I certainly think about this for a
second
Forum layout function which I've still
never figured out how to use
which one Forum layout function for form
object
that
it it's operating it is not I've never
figured it out but it takes some
structured metadata and then gives a
form object or a grid or something no I
mean look date string has this kind of
stuff as well it has a way of specifying
sort of a template for what gets put
together
okay hold on yeah
the main Su is this becomes more
poignant when the separator is a pattern
when the specified separator is pattern
right that's that's the case that's
particularly
interesting
if it's just a repeated character then
you can basically just slap it on but if
it's
a significant sequence or a meaningful
pattern then yeah
okay hold on
I mean
the obvious function would be one where
every other element is the separator
see what I'm saying hmm
the separators are basically riffled
into the list yep
kind of like a version of string split
that keeps the delimiters as extra
elements yeah
string cleave
well or
an argument structure for string split
that makes it do that
because it's a rule form that replaces
it puts the given value at the delimiter
and so it's about at the position of
each delimiter
well it's essentially what we want we
just want pattern goes to itself
yeah I've done that before
X colon blog Arrow X
all right but that doesn't get the
before or after case where you then want
to partition and string join the
sublists
oh we can deal with that I mean that's a
10 million different things you might
want to do though
but if you want it you know the afters
you just do partition comma two
otherwise you do partition two and then
off with an offset of one
right that doesn't seem hard
no
so really all this is
a string split
I mean if if I didn't think it was a
yeah who really wants to wrap that rule
because we don't want to say string
split
string
pattern Arrow automatic or something or
inherited
that seems too obscure yeah
plus you might actually want to use
those functions
yeah you might want those literals in
there
right
so we've got to wrap the rule or we've
got to have it be something other than a
rule
and rule the leg works as well so you
can do
oh yeah there's no problem in doing this
okay X colon pattern Arrow X that will
just work correct right
it's just rather Bazaar
now another question is whether the
default case of string split with one
argument is a case where you might want
to include the um
where you might want to include what was
taken out I think not
but you might want to include the pieces
of white space so to speak
yeah I feel like that's probably
uncommon enough of a desire that having
to use the two argument form with a
white space character goes to
yeah whatever is probably okay so the
question is what could you wrap or put
in that second argument that is visibly
not
because remember split has a test there
so this is really a string split story
we had like a keep head or something to
wrap the pattern
yeah but remember the second argument is
usually a string pattern so there's no
good
well all right that's the exercise is
can we get
um
some meaningful syntax or something yeah
upper yeah
I mean it could be done with a triple
rule but I hate that
uh
all right
okay nothing else here
uh nope I think that's it for today
we've got a number of things to Circle
back to it and then another time
great okay just don't forget all the
random things that are being sent in
because there's some important ones as I
recall
yep yeah we have a running list of
everything
all right
okay see you guys later then
thanks all
bye